last time I saw you was at the Meg
you're fighting sharks and now you're
fighting it you're Salva very different
isn't it very different experience it's
quite different it is but it begs the
question because he had a series called
the fighter
you and him getting into ring kickboxing
match what are your thoughts on that
it's a good win he's a big guy you know
that you have to hit him in the right
place you go you just look over there
BAM it's so great I mean you know the
one thing about it is I just I don't
know you just got to take your hat off
to him to get in the ring and to be so
it's crazy putting himself out there
because there's no guarantees on
anything you know fight the fight game
is an unpredictable sport and has been
since time so to put your put your self
at risk but you know at the same time
there's all that greatness to gain from
from doing yourself proud which is
exactly what you did yeah see you guys
get in the ring so you would do it right
who would you and then I can't sit here
and say anybody's gonna beat me right
there's a lot of smack talk in this
movie between you and the rock there's
so good but if you had to give a speech
about how great he is let's say maybe at
his wedding or somewhere um what would
you say about this I prefer to give it
the other way around I prefer to tell
you is insecure it's you know I don't
like to puff him up any more than he
puffs himself you know
yeah did you know he doesn't like he's
got motion sickness you know when we're
driving in the McLaren
we had to CGM into the car you're 20
can't get in the car and 2 he gets free
he has terrible anxiety yeah as a motion
sickness so you know it comes out in all
hives it's a terrible thing so yeah he
would give yes one little secret Blanc
Johnson so I'm starting a petition since
the rock was the sexiest man in 2016
did your Salva 2018 Jason Statham 2019
what are your thoughts hey what are my
thoughts mm-hmm where you gonna send
that one so you get
doing a petition right now wouldn't that
be crazy yeah well yeah you know my mom
would sign it ha ha the petition you
know let those two they need it they
need a bit of a boost so be me a little
bit of a bit I need a boost they do yeah
uh your birthday's coming up July 26
well should you yeah happy birthday it's
coming up yeah yeah yeah another year or
do you have plans on celebrating with
the family you know we'll do something
I've got friends in town so we've got uh
I've got some very close friends in LA
and they're gonna be around so we'll
hang out with their kids and we'll we'll
all get together
yes something nice and easy I like that
what does it mean for you to be part of
the Fast & Furious franchise it's a
great privilege yeah for many reasons
you know franchises don't last more than
two or three and if you're lucky for
this has gone on and on and on so to be
a part of something that has great
success and great appeal around the
world is always a great sort of a sort
of great sort of handshake to what we do
you know which we try and make movies
that we have success with there's enough
to strike a chord with people and these
are there so people the fan bites on
these movies they're so passionate yeah
so it means a lot to be a party sponsor
yeah all right sexiest man 2013 you said
it